[Music]
hello there it finally happened the
imagined order took to the skies in the
live event and ended the reign of the
alien mothership the new season cubed is
here right now and this is the series in
which we break down the map changes and
predict the future linking everything we
can back to story so sit your butt down
for 10 minutes slap in code adamaru to
keep this series going and let's see
what season 8 has in store for us all
the mothership has finally left the
skyline above our heads we can see the
sunshine again huzzah that mother ship
is now the vista to the north showing
its final resting place somehow it
missed the island but spots of the
island are covered with debris from the
sky fire battle for example the mountain
top above misty is missing an entire
chunk of rock face and some io bases
have crumbled to the ground but mostly
they all landed in areas where nobody
even lives the island is now inhabited
by multiple kevin the cubes but
surprisingly they are not coming to life
just yet i have no doubt bullets will
activate them soon enough and we'll see
them rolling once again the two biggest
things we've learned at the live event
were also cube related a golden cube
seemed so far in the distance most of us
missed it and the cube we rebooted and
thus turned blue both of these beauties
made it onto the island the golden cube
currently sits near holly hedges and the
blue cube the community wants to call
blevin is currently down near camp cod
he can heal your wounds by the way pay
him a visit without a doubt we need to
keep an eye on both these multicoloured
cubes as they are likely the two forces
doing battle this season the other big
changes to the map are due to the crash
zones epic have geniusly used energy
waves that kept the ufos afloat last
season to create slipstreams like those
seen in season 9 of chapter 1. oh and
one last mahusiv update as it's
halloween season the zombie hordes are
back this time they are kept in a huge
pimple on the map which changes location
the sideways from the inside this place
is literal hell with hordes bum-rushing
players but the rewards here are
interesting new weapon types with
upgradeable rarities using the life
forces the horde leaves behind right
that's all the big stuff let's find the
small things the map updates that hint
to the future let's go
[Music]
on my first drop of the season i always
check up on graham the gnome the real
hero of this story we're just waiting
for him to make his move it's been a
long time coming and yes he still just
sat there anyway there is a secret
around here to find go down into the
recording studio below and you'll find a
passageway blocked next to the stairs go
down to find a secret bunker someone
lives here it looks well lived in and
whilst i was destroying this place to
find more secrets i accidentally found a
secret doorway inside it is this
recognize it if you watched last season
you'll know this item was cordoned off
over on spawn island i surmised that
this was an object of power like those
seen in control and alan wake and it
just so happens that alan wake has a
remake coming next month this item could
be linked to that a filing cabinet could
be important to the story of fortnite
i'll be sure to keep an eye on this spot
and let you know if anything changes
while we're at this location venture a
little north to find a spot of alien
supporters after the event at believer
beach many of the locals have made this
spot a party campsite and depending on
when you arrive the local wildlife seem
to be enjoying it too
the entire reason why they've set up
here is due to the cliff top houses
nearby by the looks of it one of those
houses is occupied by one of the chimera
the low gravity field is intact the
alien decor is all around so i think
it's safe to say someone survived that
devastating war and just wants to go on
with their life
so some of the i o outposts were
destroyed after the sky fire event and
that has prompted sloane and io to build
new outposts much much smaller than
those we saw last season designed as
watch towers once again formulating a
plan for the latest invasion attempts io
have done some strange things this
season they've gone so far to disrupt
travel on the roads by setting up
roadblocks and checks
likely this is to find the impostors
among us some of the io quick setup
bases are actually here to begin the
cleanup of the island here near the
docks you can find some heavy duty
machinery set to recover the crash
debris which leads me to think that the
scrapyard will likely update this season
and look it's already started right now
the ufos from the believer beach
celebration are resting here junk
disregarded and unwanted this place will
be very busy over the weeks to come as
the island is a complete mess another
cleanup is underway over at holly hedges
this one stronghold of the last reality
is reverting back to the original
version of holly but it's not complete
just yet pictures are going up furniture
is being uncovered the world is
reverting once again there's also a
truck carrying away the final remains of
alien tech and have you noticed
something about that truck it's an
official i o vehicle
am i writing thinking that this is the
first time io have brought out a
freaking truck
it looks very official
so this next update really interests me
below pleasant park some of the ground
has been smashed to smithereens
uncovering this
yet another bunker those who know the
law will know that these are the ways
into the i o facility below and access
to the zero point previously we knew of
three of these things and just to make
sure i checked they're all still here
one to the north of the island below
this shack another is underwater to the
west side of the island and the third is
under a bush to the east of retail row
all still here all still fully intact
that means this is the fourth hatch and
it must be important going forward i
have no idea how i have no idea why i
just know it's important the fourth
bunker okay that sounds pretty cool the
fourth bunker like usual i checked up on
the tiny chair this week and
surprisingly it's made it through the
aftermath of war but look how close it
came to disaster the io base next door
isn't really in one piece anymore so
thank you fortnight gods for sparing
this i also made my trip to the
sheriff's office and the gnomes stuck in
captivity i've waited like six months
for something to happen here and it has
well not completely here but this may be
the season where the genome army finally
rises up
next time you're in lazy lake have a
look-see here
graham and his enforcer are discussing
something which involves explosives and
gas canisters could this be for a
jailbreak of the gnomes nearby
i haven't seen the sheriff around much
so now is a good time to rescue our boys
and the biggest news of all for last
penny is now an npc in fortnite battle
royale i know this is inconsequential to
everyone else but this marks the end of
my push to get bigger girls in fortnite
br big girls you are beautiful but in
this scenario there can be only one
she's at retail row if you want to visit
her right so that's what i spotted in my
first few hours of season eight how did
i do and what the heck did i miss please
let me know and if there's enough
updates next time i will try my best to
keep the series going please let me know
if this series has outstayed its welcome
i keep changing my mind on this thanks
for watching and an extra special thank
you to those who use code adamaru last
season here's a bunch of legends who
helped me out thank you very much
appreciate ya i'm adam you're awesome
see you next time
[Music]
you